Ready, steady, can't hold me back Ready, steady, give me
good luck Ready, steady, never look back Let's get started,
ready, steady, go Flick, flick, flick, flick
If you move on to the right way, I'll kill you, but the real
enemy will now see you already long as I can see you I'm
telling you, I'm telling you I'm telling you, I'm telling
you I'm telling the truth This is how I'm telling you toар
with me I'm super excited I can't think about you me,
hard-earned-sake-so-no-do-tok-nari It's the only way to hear
Your voice, your voice Where there's no time for no time So
ready, stay calm
I can't even hear any kisses Even if I'm not holding my
hands It's just a yes, it's a sound but my soul won't be
able to take away On that other side of the hill if you ever
meet me, I'd love to know what else to tell me?
I just think that's all I think so I'm just so much in it
I'm just so excited to get over it.
It's so noisy, it's like a hide-and-sake The sound of the
chord of the tachonari Kibbyte Yeah!
In your voice Here, there's no time for no time So ready,
steady,
go Ready,
steady, can't hold me back Ready, steady, give me good luck
Ready, steady, never look back Let's get started ready, so
we go Oh
Sii From the sky,
the sky The circularity of the spirit The screaming dice
There are no longer I can't stop you Even though Don't let
me I'm sure I'm a little bit A little bit more A little bit
more Stay calm Please, trust me